sipping on my Blue Bottle coffee I'm not
gonna lie to here and I should be upon
these nuts
I shall we step off you sip on these big
black nuts well you don't have a black
rifle nuts what I got boy well that's a
huge mug there how much mug this ain't
for you do looks like a manly monk who
bottle what a stupid name
well I don't care I'm for me I drink my
coffee and I like it I like it textured
that's probably all male and dark and
roasty this is the largest mug of it
I've got citrus notes in mine all kinds
of things I was just at Blue Bottle and
they were having a coffee tasting you
want to see nerds god bless him I love
other people there I mean nerding out of
it you know that's when you know you're
dealing with the whitest of the white
people cuz they still they grind their
own whites only
oh yeah well coffee coffee because I
don't know get into the RV tastings why
don't well the Japanese are obsessed
with coffee too now they're as well but
you see it's mostly white it's mostly a
specific kind of white person so same
with wine tasting you live in Napa
wine-tasting though is now huge in China
and different places but it's getting
there but well no white still odor yeah
yeah yeah yeah I know people are getting
into it I don't think just white well
the wine market is supported by China
but I you're right at the end of the day
when you don't want you don't want
tasting it's gonna be yeah you're gonna
see some whites but the coffee is a kind
of white with the hipster kind of with
sometimes long beards sometimes not a
beard sometimes very it's a really
interesting uniformity it's a Portland
Oregon uniform instead sort of a Seattle
hipsters kind of the skin is again you
don't see a lot for whatever is you know
their skin doesn't hit a lot of Sun a
lot of times or shut it they'll really
might catch on dad catch on fire they're
vampires
these guys were these guys were scooping
there was a way to scoop apparently with
a spoon yes I had to do that for black
rifle making the big brown rose my
question is for a ton of them how do you
do that how do you get the coffee the
taste from that coffee out of your mouth
and they have like a sparkling water
thing that you can clean they keep
trying it gotta clear your palate yeah
did like 30 of them by the time you hit
my pants yeah number time view to the
end it's like alright I mean dark rose
bro you the darkest of the dark
yeah just give me a dark roast let's not
overthink things
it's called Hills roast make it real
hazard Jesus what house rusty that's
good name
who's that Matt best hells rose house
roast roast this [ __ ] down in hell the
deep roast you should say hell's roast
and then in parenthesis we roast this
[ __ ] down in hell in case you missed the
metaphor Satan's roasting Satan's roast
fueled by sins these beans were roasted
by sins by saying by your sin by your
sin yeah roasted in sin oh [ __ ] man
roasted in Sin City you goose you have
fun in Arizona huh yeah I hate the
wagering that stupid Cup mm-hmm get a
gayer cup I'm not going to it was fun in
Phoenix when they're good you wanted a
grand old time just the guys hanging out
that's what that's so much fun cuz
usually I'm on the road it's just me and
Jamie Jay have a great time but in the
green room was just with comics I don't
know does Yumi re do big Jason hilarious
agent Justin was there's a good time
yeah man
owner from zany's or Brian Dorfman rind
or from the owner of many clubs it was a
good time wasn't it yeah a really good
time just a bunch of guys sitting there
eating but you were onto something
hey I did too you want to talk about it
well you're gonna say what you eat
though are you talking about the we time
at the carne asada I hate I I didn't
just eat the carne asada then I had I
went double my double Jam I doubled down
on the on the chili green chili chicken
and I ate two things of rice now you got
out of this shitty my second show I was
having some trouble dude that green
chili I looked at it and went you know
I'm gonna try out so I went you know
what yeah I don't feel like [ __ ] my
pants in Phoenix right believe this
someone else and you found it you
practiced restraint well I did yeah I
went I double down I had two giant meals
and I wasn't hungry I'm not I'm still
not hungry yeah I'm [ __ ] hungry
literally I haven't I haven't quite been
right since do that's a lot of food yes
but I think we're on with some of that
show we're not reinventing the wheel
here now by blue comet or dinner or the
Kings of Comedy
yep did it but I think that that's a
good formula to trickle in
once a month once every two months you
do this kind of all-star list of
headliners four or five guys you and I
and friends you know when I moved me CEO
Andrew Santino Bobby Lee
Ari Shaffir big J we all do 25 everyone
does everyone does their work and then
we hang out maybe we were there for two
shows one night or two maybe we shoot
sunny antics backstage maybe we put that
up on YouTube I don't know we'll see
what happens called the big dick energy
tour big dick energy tour power clowns
something like that fat dicks are us but
you but have the are like the old no I'm
not doing that I backed it up do you
don't have that stupid [ __ ] giraffe
as are like opener nope
no he come down to I don't know if
that's a good idea unless he's out of
this and he's a job bro
he comes out and he's like dude and I
throw and I come flying out and I throw
him in a flying headlock I'd be sick or
you know you come out and you jump on
his head and he and he and we kill the
giraffe I'd be cool what a stupid the
kind of mascot Toys R Us was the bomb
when you're a kid though but they're out
of business now did you ever go to their
huge store in New York City in Manhattan
the one that was featured in the movie
big they help it do Biggs's Schwartz you
old [ __ ] I feel shorts tomorrow right
I'll get the [ __ ] that went out of
business I think they're coming back
they are yeah FAO Schwartz comeback is a
pop-up shop and bum everybody else guys
you're right that was FAO jumped here
you can star it now it's an Apple store
FAO Schwartz was also featured in home
alone - yes yes it was Russ was featured
in what nothing nada
no that's bro oh I just had they were
they there big one was out here in LA so
remember dad brought us out here there's
like a big are you you and toys I bet
you were all over that [ __ ] right and
[ __ ] all those dude glowworm my pet
monster Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles The
Wrestler figurines much a man I didn't
have any of that
no you collected four words I collected
I'm sorry what did you just say rocks I
did collect rocks in fact yeah it's a
rocket in fact there are a couple things
I collected rocks bugs and bad men and
knives I was thinking looking back on it
a bit of a weird kid you know what right
if I was a kind of analyzing your
childhood you and uh Jeffrey Dahmer like
the same [ __ ] as kids so bugs animals
rocks
yep knives and humans so my mother came
in on me I was in just a somber mood and
I was probably jacking 18 no sir no I
don't think no I was last program I was
not doing that but I was hanging sort of
off my bed where my head was hanging
upside down and watching I was playing
possum house playing possum and I was
watching my snake my ball python eat rat
that I put in there and it struck and
caught it and Pink Floyd was playing my
mother walked in and saw me watching
this thing hanging upside down
and she goes I don't like this I don't
like this I don't like this dark thing
that's going on in this room she was
afraid I was becoming a moody a weirdo
teenager yeah I could do something who
knows you know well I want you I don't
think you should be hanging like that
and watching this I think that was like
I'm I'm you know mean something good
yeah I'm not really I'm not a moody guy
and I'm not down I go what the I'm
listening to for me was I'm just
listening to Pink Floyd and I'm watching
my snaky hey and I didn't like killing
any brats jacking on no that's not a
nice man
cuz no moms can be like oh no I didn't
have her dad laughter snake killing
innocent that would have been I find
weird that would have been very weird if
I was if I was like you'd like way down
you don't white mouse almost down off
the life of them
yeah yeah choke on it yeah yeah deep
throat that Mouse
didn't there's me throat into that do
you know what take you know it all snake
that is for 10 points to bow constricted
no it's not that's it guest dude look
it's not the ball python that's right
the other stupid qualms
it's everyone as a ballplayer I was like
I'm the i'ma snake expert it's a red
tail boa whatever ball python it finds
next to be fascinating and they say that
we people who have a natural phobia of
snakes it's because you have a genetic
memory of it because primates are
naturally yeah not me not me just a
[ __ ] snake just a lizard with no legs
like Oh what are you afraid of it what
do you what makes you squeamish
terrorist beasts you don't like
terrorists freaked me out man okay okay
that's fair um what else don't you like
what makes you scream aside okay like a
tarantula child molesters okay okay
that's not okay and then if they I
understand that make sense make sense
but I'm so I'm so centipedes for me mmm
they they make me lose like that yeah so
give me what what makes you who dang
Bariloche son chin thank you for that
you're walking for a number one for that
guy that guy has that on hand
yeah that's an I would never let spray
our boy yes that's our boy you know
that's Tyler Peterson that's my thinking
I would be too afraid to do that I would
never do that now now that she knows his
own merch you do look at him let me see
I like that stand out bronc sweatshirt
pink looks good on huh that is your own
merch guard got my heart cart okay you
know I'm trying to count alive you
should capitalize he's really sick you
know start releasing singles chin chin
is an artistic man he should be doing
that of course that looks pretty good on
you thank you you like two layers on
your head at all times it's amazing in
here at least and plus in here it's it's
beneficial but but you really like to
have you you prefer things on your head
you know this already
I know it's interesting it's a personal
endeavor not it's a feeling it do you
like to be a little bit anonymous you
like to be a little bit hidden little
cozy it up yeah do you think it's from
the days you're 300 pounds yeah problem
that's right that's probably part of it
yeah you know that's traumatic right oh
yeah in a way like I talked to will
South
about that like when you're really big
like that it is a very traumatic feeling
like it feels like you're not I don't
know maybe you're trapped in your body
or something chance came out the other
side wills kind of still into it yeah
but he used to be used to be really
really yeah he's just a big no matter
even if he died it's a big crazy he's
gonna be a big dude you know you do a
lot even if you lose weight like I
remember I had like just a lean stomach
I'd still pull down my shirt often yes
we'll always has fifteen shirts and he's
always got to change his shirt always
volleyball shirt ocean shirt yes cat
woody what did you do this weekend
literally just worked you working like
crazy yeah but I'm not here I'm there
damn in the bougie place in the bougie
play are they being I still don't know
actually saw Kourtney Kardashian's
ex-boyfriend bother day oh yeah yeah
good looking you in person he's yeah
he's he's small though small that I
thought yeah yeah a little small number
iron
who does she have a new boyfriend I
think so he's cute her new boyfriend's
really really really young guy like 20
yeah that's guys this is one you saw
right he's a cutie pie geez Middle
Eastern yeah yes and then the new guy is
black is he mmm who's the new black guy
he's a yes you knew she was gonna head
that direction yeah eventually the whole
family yeah you're not really a crazy a
sheer pressure go boy even the mom did
suck all the black even mom did also mom
was like I want in the club oh yeah it's
like it's so strange I mean you know
it's it's like I want to be part of the
cool Club this guy mm-hmm whoa I had a
girlfriend say to me oh that's her man
yeah get the [ __ ] out it was he 13 20
what is it mustache like that no that's
not her no is it really yes yeah is
there a picture of them together yeah oh
she's into boys yeah I had two
girlfriends who after we dated just
blatantly one was like I want a date
plan I want to date a black guy I go why
she goes because I think they're awesome
I was like okay you go ahead and do that
that's a great story I'm not a girl but
after me I was like what I do why
yeah but dude she's 40-something oh she
is either together 18:20 she looks like
his mama that's just a new trend no he
lays down that young dick yeah a
generation Z dick call Finn or die my
brother dick yeah lays down that gen Z
right right LAN I had this theory on
Danza I mean not the best I mean I got a
theory on dick size
I believe that if you see a dude who
moves slowly whereas baggy pants kind of
lanky he's got a dick on him the Big Dig
when you see and it could be a black guy
doesn't matter if this if the guy talks
his shirt in a lot of he walks with a
clip that energy yeah has a car cover
you know I mean he keeps just everything
is like just like the car he's working
with small dick he's working with a
regular dick or regular to smaller I
remind this fascinating though that's
her new man how old is she
40 early forties is that right what do
you want but he did she's the oldest
sister yeah huh then close what does she
know yeah her Chloe Kim 39 and she's
part of the she's on that show yeah
Kardashian's that I've never so she she
prints money Brian she does and she
likes to print money okay they're all
doing pretty well
they all just print their own money so
you got to give it up to the at the end
of the day Miss Kris Jenner who was the
one who really I don't have to write
really him really rages on that lit this
fire but you don't say took it and ran
with it
right yeah but he's kind of yeah or did
they ever they dare ever so Ray J just
banged Courtney I mean what's him but he
was the first one first one and then
Reggie Bush right but but but but it was
it was when they reshot scenes and post
of it that [ __ ] knowledge now she looked
like Jafar from Aladdin okay she's not
she's not used to had a recognizer
yes Jafar from Aladdin let me see
another pair now she's a straight died
piece so Ray J really didn't [ __ ] her
wait a minute that was her back then
yeah leaked geobella that's not her
that's not courting that's not Kim
credit yeah to get the beak bro hold on
Jafar from unless she did have plastic
surgery on her face to help I don't know
I don't follow these things well I mean
come on but I liked her then
although she looks better now baby she I
mean you know me I I don't encourage you
and going to the knife but God bless
that doctor well I don't know who he is
I'm not a fan of plastics I don't really
see I think she's hot there too but yeah
she's alright there's games looks like
Jafar and that's her today look at her
now
they went snip snip yeah I don't like
that though it took that I liked her
before I don't like when people look to
pulled up I'm gonna get some serious
plastic surgery that I'm gonna look
great they just stays doing the damn
thing how about if I have my eyes
tightened just a little bit watch it
wouldn't hurt bro watch just feet be
real come on boy being salty I'm not
I'll pay for okay I'll be looking at
your set don't [ __ ] say that to me I
have great personality I know your faith
a fetal now watch not just hold on it's
gonna be subtle okay all right keep an
open mind don't be a dick all right dude
also hey be careful because you're
trending on racism there with the Oh
Asian eyes now if you slit your little
eyes everyone here's gonna be offended
don't say slit your little eyes you've
already installed bill you can't tire
like cat's fist practically boost your
racism cat's fist okay then just hold on
but yeah hey be careful don't grab the
sides and pull your eyes about rabbit
axe we're going bad on our cat I was
like hey bro you better calm down don't
go bad on our cat we love her all right
ready yeah put a little higher in your
temple see you bro just relax
do reduces kids and now I find it
offensive you look like Spock that's a
good thing right
mmm Botox and the wrinkles on your
forehead won't kill you
I'm not getting Botox on my forehead
would you ever do it nope you know what
you need you need on the line right I
know I do I've heard I'd just yeah I had
a dermatologist say to me he goes he's
from Russia comes out he goes you sell
that I can I can change all that I can
get rid of all of it no thank you yeah
because you do that I'm gonna roast you
every day but the thing is because my
face wouldn't move on your face isn't
moving well no that's why I can see the
Botox now and everybody help me too it's
only if you go too overboard I think
yeah but but your face is still that
botulism
I'm surprised Donald Trump yes like
Lydia's nutsack saying up on his eyes
they can take care of that can they yeah
it's fat that opposed to she's that true
yeah so show when you get surgery guys
get for it Wow yeah wow really yeah
don't Trump has nut sack saying if the
baby
did he have he did he looked like he had
no wrinkles for a little while but not
no wrinkles but way less wrinkles he's
known for his wrinkles good little one
is that him in the middle it looks like
he is no no down down this one no no
down down is somewhere else
Montana Tim says before during after
allergies or something oh maybe it's a
yeah yeah me too
maybe maybe I can get my my eyes pulled
up a little chin would you ever get any
plastic surgery no I mean I've had Botox
yeah you're such an interesting guy I
absolutely love ya
yep hey where'd you get it done it like
the mandible area what's that the cheeks
it's not the cheek it's like they call
it masseter on your jowls like right
here your jaw
why'd you do it they're your victims
don't so you're chewing on them oh
they're still alive or what is it it's
four teeth grinding but it also makes
your face a little bit slimmer - so you
got it four teeth grinding teeth
grinding originally but then it made
your face Koreans get a [ __ ] makes your
fit face on my face before that [ __ ]
what do they just do it here like give
me clench your teeth can you feel the
muscles like going out yeah
like big you know it'll shrink your face
a lot I mean not that much though it'll
be a big difference I've never done say
no more fam needs to shrink their face
some people Kat would you ever get you
haven't had any plus sir do you have to
tell us if he did your lips are a little
suspect they're bigger than mine you
should see my sister's liver cells had
nope no I know it's true she's like the
biggest ho I know love her sisters yeah
for reals yeah that's a damn call she's
younger than me her name is Kat Foom
damn cat squared
she had me mad at him for saying this no
I say that all the time people at Target
at restaurants Clark
oh all the time this is how we speak but
that's I call her the postmates of [ __ ]
she looks like you she looks more like
my mom let's see if she want to come in
and like chatter she like cuz really
good for another internal flow or not
402 so I don't know if she's like down
for a cop and dick suck but the thing is
it's what did you say that's a great
coffee oh yeah I thought you all right
ed what huh Brendon be a mentor let me
be a Bentley she and our control Shinda
like I don't know high-level podcasters
commands no she is into football players
but she was really young football you
know we can show we can chuck the old
pigskin around yeah and I can give her
guidance as an older man yeah Bryce you
ain't coming to hang out with me now we
won't be able to get over the show t
shows an older very cute how old is she
dan you gather a good-looking family say
don't work she's quite quite pretty
Natalie how old you say she's 21 just
turned 21
illegal white that's the only thing I
don't look like I'm doing wife uh-huh
usually the same girls that like black
guys like me no no I don't think you're
thick enough though she likes them like
real thick
what do you mean like real thick like
this fat like the thick guys on the team
I don't know oh she likes are you a
lineman yes could you miss like [ __ ]
Allah in the middle though up I'm Chu
how much - 50 and I'm under 250 now now
you are which is weird because she's
like 411 and like honey she likes to
ride the polar bear
she likes to jump in that polar bear she
likes to die and she likes a giant she
don't jump on now the big brown town
yeah so when X and X
ex-boyfriends would be dangerous for a
guy like me she likes it she wants to
[ __ ] Larry Allen
oh she like does she like black eye yeah
and and and then just black um not just
black but she seems to only date black
guys like she thinks other ethnicities
are
unless she only ever really like is that
her ideal man right there number 73 yes
yes looking but like the everything else
yes I wonder what it was in her child
cuz they say something your childhood
happens I think I know what it is
she had really traumatic sexual
experiences with her first like three
guys like first you guys Minutemen
tiny dick and then one too big could not
fit those region the station yeah and
the last one was blacked with the two
big fat dick no I think she just really
got into football and then she started
DMing guys god bless her she's still
football fan yeah this is wifey son yeah
she still watches he's got a whole
lineup yeah
god bless her I mean I think it's great
will figures living her best life she's
living the fullest I was gonna say I'm
how I don't know where we go from little
may be a moment of silence for your
hotter sister liking basically big brown
yeah she's a big black Brennan has a
real pension for black women yeah
Brennan will you love your you might be
as attracted to black women as more than
your you have a bit of that as well I
don't discriminate no you you definitely
do you only like the white race and I
well they have they have to be from the
north no one is there from they can be
any part of Scandinavia well they gotta
be Gabby southern scandinavia he's got
to be more than or i need the kind of
white that blends with shane you ever
dated a black chick nah no no cat black
guy no black guy some mexican guys
dinner'll like me growing up it was
until I got like my my tits came in and
I started to look it'll say like it
wasn't twelve cuz I look like I was
twelve until I was like 18
you know I guess have a like the
attractive jowls
what's an attractive jaw it's a defined
jaw soft but define take it from their
full mouth curvy bodies yes people are
good-looking people not all of all no no
no all of them okay I've done a study
Filipinos though Vietnamese they're
good-looking people my tribe me under
other trickier though the ladyboys
oh my Oh Jin and then you go up and then
they have these fat dick I was I was in
Thailand with like cast The Hangover and
where the lady boys went watch them
dance and one of them was stroking I
think is Brody Stevens and I was like
dude if you went with this [ __ ] it
you are not gay you're not gay because
they're so fat that's what they look
like so you explained to me that second
one in I'd be [ __ ]
literally the this one I like this first
one second one yeah that one this one
they're all do you like the one that
looks like the dude in the back tell
them I'll line up look at the one with
the hips that's a cow for me those were
wide hips yeah that's a girl looks like
Tom Brady's lower body what I'm drawn to
that I'm drawn to it look good trick you
man yeah they'll trick you does she
signs today yeah what would happen is
we'd get all the guy on the ride down
the guy on the left no sir you gotta do
better you know you look like you like a
dude who put on a red eye immediately
that loser guys right away the one in
the middle I'd like to I kind of funky
the one on the right would get away with
it cuz she's got cleavage if it was late
at night you get away with it guy left
her like hey bro yeah it's not here huh
what happens in these situations is
we're hanging out we're drunk good time
you're gonna bathroom I let me go in
there done it I'm like ah Brendan
alright it's mums the word yeah but
there with with oh it was science like
there was one I watched on TLC man she
was she's still killing it I don't get
you man
I'll get you you know some people say
booty hoes of booty holes well I can
tell this story um our boy Stevie I met
him out and uh this is about a year ago
maybe I met him out maybe a little more
actually maybe a year and a half and he
was with this just blow out just blow
out tits and ass I mean crazy mouth I
was like what I there's Austin with you
go ahead nope
no this was in Los Angeles met him they
were at crossroads the vegan restaurant
so I was good my boy Travis okay and so
I was going met him good guy I was on my
way to the The Improv met them there and
I went and I went it was a kind of a
first date for him didn't know and I
looked at her and I was like wow she's
very curvy and she got up hugged me gave
me a kiss and went wow you're sexy and I
went this is an interesting situation
forward I was like this is an
interesting Sigma situation but wearing
them like no bra with just he's crazy in
the nipples and I was like and people
were looking at her which she would walk
by it at all um very good question but a
good five eight yeah not too alarming no
not too alarming my might my man made
our radar display a little bit a little
bit a little aggressive she is and and
that's a great live what's funny is that
I went that's a hot dude chick not yet
okay but might but there wasn't in me
and there was a in kind of everybody as
she walked there's something Oh
everyone's attracted to her a little bit
like there's something gonna be but I
just couldn't figure out what was going
on either could Stevie I go what do you
mean hey I said what are you thinking he
goes I don't know I I can't figure it
out you know I'm so we hang we're
walking and then she says something like
well I'm there's a lot of me I'm a lot
like a guy in a lot of ways ah because
we were talking about sexuality and
stuff and I was like hmm so we're
walking and I'm looking I look at her
ass look at her body looking at her gait
I don't up the way she walks no that's
tough to do and and what happens is
there's an overcompensation so she's
walking super sexy she's making an
effort to just walk super sexy because
her balls are pinching in the middle of
it well well well
maybe but she was wearing there's no way
that balls and [ __ ] could fit in what
she was wearing be surprised you would
be scenes because Levi's gets it done
they were Levi's they were tee there
were white jeans dude so anyway he's now
she's sitting on Stevie's lap in the
thing
she's caressing him and stuff like that
and Stevie comes back out and he goes I
don't know where it is
I'm just not attracted to her and I go I
know what it is what she used to be a
fella buddy and he goes do you think and
I go watch this I go right to the people
next whistle the girl that he was with
they go yeah I go something's up right
and they go we can't figure it out but
there's something up I go like what do
you think and he goes why I don't want
to say you saying his girl goes I think
she might have been a guide brilliant I
went and I agree long story short he
drives her home
Stevie sucks Am I Stevie he does not but
Stevie just goes Stevie goes well you
know I like I said I go you gotta hit it
he goes he goes nope certain get there
and he said and she says something else
about being a guy she kind of like I
lose to another thing like what she says
I'm usually one of the boys so you can
it's all good we can hang out it you
know why that you know I a lot of times
people transgender people say this
because they're trying to give you hints
because if you do go the bedroom they
don't get beat up yeah and also that's
right there are a lot of reasons but my
mother said sounds like my mother says
something maybe a little bit of the
yellow scuffle well my mother said
something interesting about it my mother
said you might have when you're with
someone like that and I want you to look
this up to see if this is true um he may
have the skin temperature might be
different it might be more else maybe
and and smell might be different so
there's a different kind of smell a
different kind of deal it's calls good
vo it's just called guys it's called
it's called testosterone over do and you
nuts let's see this skin temperature and
males versus females let's see that this
is my mother the other thing I throws
you off is she referred to in his bro so
that's not gonna help
no she know she didn't know by tempor
how difference for men and women
it is Mondays medical myth you know men
are hotter than women women have
naturally cooler bodies than men well
their circulation of the blood is why
higher core temperature more body fat
and fluctuating hormones huh it's a
stretch might have been burning hotter
it's a stress
pick up no because we pick up on really
subtle cues as human beings like really
subtle [ __ ] pheromones Adam's apple no
you don't hand see that on her butt hand
and you can't hide see and hide long
enough size 14 but she wasn't eater she
was not a big guy or girl but but I'd
love to see a picture we pick up on
really lose my thing Stevie I mean a
couple things you he doesn't talk about
it here well don't don't giveaways joke
here's my thing Stevie might be into it
just to hear me out Steve you don't keep
BBQ me up for this but you've been in
prison bro you're in there quite some
time just the home Stevie's as straight
as you and I oh dude wait wait look
where those had chicks with huge dicks
get that off the screen god I'm trying
to make this show more substantive well
there goes target noise as a sponsor
mm-hmm okay
oh there's their hand that's a big hand
it's clearly I do but those are Thai
gals when you see you know how you love
to the European extractions white males
are the toughest pol yeah white big
Moens no Samoans if you're Samoan let's
go times I saw I was at the Century City
Mall with my son and there was a in the
middle they have like a big park but
it's not that big but everyone can see
and there was some makeup line they're
dropping and they had a live DJ and I
just see this Amazon of a woman just
like each dance in like making a scene
and look like a full woman and just like
[ __ ] twerk and she worked for him and
then you close like that's a big ass
dude yeah who played for [ __ ]
University of Syracuse basketball and
decide to be a girl huge butt aesthetic
is the way he/she was dancing like
really I was like god damn you couldn't
take your eyes off of it that's pretty
cool yeah that's a bit weird dating them
I like that yeah but you cannot take
your eyes off of it no I'm not the moves
like cheese well what somebody can
really move divided on't care what they
are but it was cool it's amazing to
watch
now did some kids run away yeah they did
they're scared and some were some white
families but I had a good time sometimes
people can dance in a way that makes
people really uncomfortable I've seen
that at a wedding saw a girl it was a
real dancer dancing at a wedding and it
was very interesting because she was
sexy as all get-out and what happens is
the women the women now they each other
they're drawn to it but then they their
men are drawn to it and then it becomes
a whole situation upended octaves and
they'll shoot they'll shut it the [ __ ]
down women do not like it it's good but
nobody ever talks about what this whole
feminist movement is gino's much harder
on women than men a lot of times other
women all for sure I mean ruthless
[ __ ] ruthless it is not a it is not a
band of sisters it is oh it is some of
the worst [ __ ] I've ever seen rumors not
hmm
competition Mean Girls for a reason bro
Mean Girls Mean Girls the movie it's all
kinds of stuff like jello hair shut up
Lindsay Lohan competition I don't know
man
we've been on shemales for a hot SEC you
yeah we are still wearing your eyes huh
my what somewhere in your eyes come
again your eyes sorry that's straight
for your diamonds
get out you know what it's chilly in
here innit it's so annoying to me if I
post you both yeah put the bring me
Brian's in skin video what is that
anyways I'm just sitting there I don't
know what he's doing he's crying and I'm
like okay I could really I thought he
was getting ready to go do stand-up and
he's you know he's getting doing it
ritual like that's a weird process which
one is it right there first one yeah
soon the green dragon
what are you doing any cold
I see girl I see it is what are you
talking about wise guys so that's nice
no it's not that all right get it off
get it off with some good times in
Phoenix yeah I really like it I want to
start doing more of that
yeah could be fun yeah called the Bryan
Callen extravaganza
with a bunch of other dudes Bryan and
dude Bryan some do Bryan and some dudes
Bryan and dude yeah that's fun we're in
San Francisco this weekend together dude
Friday Saturday excited about that we're
doing cobs little place called what a
great club that is yeah I'm excited
yeah favorite clubs I'm looking forward
to it I'm excited be in San Francisco
me too I'm being a friend I know I'm
Park should be in town because he's down
I just talked to him Luke's out of the
fight yeah okay cuz he was gonna use my
sock right yeah he was gonna be in New
York Corning Luke Rockhold yep
Lutz out so then that means we get Tariq
in target you know I'll be an empowered
Jim picking his brain yeah learning to
fight a boy yo SIV would be out there we
have got that delicious songs we gotta
go to Suns gotta go to Suns
how great is that it's my favorite ah
Hawaiian burger I know dude the food
there is so good that's all Lebanese
Egyptian food yeah
something else they have they have that
city on lockdown in every great
restaurant it's unbelievable was it last
time with her no that's I was by myself
cause but then I was there before and
yosef he's a cop our boys a cop out
there he took me the Tenderloin district
and I went into this crack house it was
that was a tough one just awkward only
can I get a bulletproof vest or
something which he did
I use throwing stars yes that's it right
there for embark I'm sorry Sam Barker
Darrow
you like you like Sam Frank yet I love
San Francisco
you could have any shows you want to
come to cat let us know yeah if I ever
get day off work let me know you and
your sister what oh if you want someone
older no my dad's good no no no a mom
cuz my mom my mom you don't my mom so I
told your mom my mom's around your age
but you show old bribry
your mom women Asian do not Asian women
do not age like all others they age well
and then all of a sudden go they're like
a prune in the night like you left a
[ __ ] like A Raisin in the Sun you've
left left to peer out overnight and they
just [ __ ] shrimp up mm-hmm
why was your someone's hatin on your mom
your mom's probably not on Instagram huh
it's probably best
should we try and hook up your mom and
Callen Kent
I don't think Alan's my mom's type hmm
what's your mom into black guys - no
she's strictly Vietnamese guys mom
doesn't like it I'm she doesn't she says
that all the time the only reason why
I'm with your dad is because I don't
like to try new things do that's safe
you have an honest family I like it I
mean people are medically correct now
they're dirt you've Dan there's a very
honest I don't think Koreans are
politically correct either right
typically mmm there's not not within the
household for sure yeah there's protocol
John I feel like the flavor in your
house is from your you your mom and your
sister your dad's kind of just along for
the ride that fair to say
no my dad was a very very wild man in
his day oh yeah yeah he without getting
too
much details he's the type of guy to
meet a girl at a party a Mexican girl
who is visiting family from Mexico
follow her to Mexico without speaking a
lick of English live with her for a year
come back after he dumps her he's a
romantic
he's a real romantic you still like he
likes to [ __ ] he's also a romantic
that's when you fall in love for a year
Oh move in for a year and you follow a
woman to another country and you don't
speak the language you find that she was
painfully hot I would say balsam I
follow a girl to Syria right now she's
hot yeah that's true that'll happen like
do you know unsafe it is I'm like we'll
figure it out yeah don't worry
there are there's a certain type of
hotness I will follow to Syria yep
you drive your car cross-country for in
the middle of the night that's right
it's it's all worth it it's what drives
you there you go well goddamn that's her
right now just like a flashback Friday
[ __ ]
yeah Brian's are looking he's I like it
have we here what have we mama
yeah she your mom's the first sister
give me the American by the way by the
way this is my bow what's her real name
ten this is my [ __ ] mom's my egg by
the way like T a n yeah I'm done this
would be my most would be my pick up
line
cat good to see you and I don't believe
you introduced me to your sister Tiffany
Donna is it oh that's a razor don't be I
thought you're gonna have something for
this no no I took why I didn't do it
right Kat's so good to see you I don't
believe you've introduced me to your
sister Tiffany is it that same [ __ ] not
very good
all right get her with so much dad how
are you it's so good to see you mmm I
don't believe you've introduced me to
your friend sister it is your sister's
it's not Tiffany um that's worse so how
my voice goes low though no it's were
Domino's no I feel like you need to do
something to okay
oh god how are you who's the lady to
your left
you ever take a ride in a Tesla
Oh who's duh who's your friend on the
left I need a few balut eggs for her
do you watch the Goldbergs hey and just
let me know if this would work on your
mom cat
I got a few bluets at my house what a
balut and dick suck
what's a balut what is that oh yeah a
little lot you know what it is oh yeah
blue ticks I raised my own blood I think
you want to stop hey you want to stop
you want to stop a bird from hatching a
couple weeks early what do we eat some
bird feeders what say we get that bird
before cracks egg on its own huh what
say we kill that little thing little
innocent hey I got an idea
I just [ __ ] I just hard-boiled a
bunch of birds that are about to hatch
how about we go
shehram open up together and you suck my
dick yeah you want to eat some pre
hatchling with a spoon you want to stop
you want to kill a bird in the egg and
I'd eat it with a spoon
how's that sound that turn you on is
there any type of thing mama cat yeah he
ended bullets here's the other thing I
got a [ __ ] gallon of fruit punch as
well why don't we swallow that then wash
it down it out wash it down with some
how about split a baby bird and some
fruit pot well you suck nothing I like
more than nothing like I like more than
a blood then I button some punch
I'm just throw three three things out
there mama cat Saturday night get on the
fruit punch blue tag my dick ha ha
nothing I enjoy more that's that is that
not in time Oh friend brag I'll be there
mo from ripening everyone Brian get me
in the corner sipping a fresque and
jacking off that cool fresca older man's
drink a balut a lot balloon there dick
suck bro yeah just play up for your mom
cat let me know what stinks got it can't
guarantee fruit punch though we got some
curved vets Jen yes you know that's
family you know it's not a lot of happy
stories around this time time don't you
not bring up the shootings no no no no
so that means we've got a
step up to you know alright let's start
off with the world and make it light
guys cats I wonder if we shouldn't bring
this up Sam so and this is going so the
Simpsons writers are planning to write
off a poo
because of the controversy around him
just because he's a ethical or they
they're thinking they're making fun of
the Indian race well Kanata
there was a documentary that came out
last year that was called the problem
with a poo where there was an Indian
comic talking about how he grew up in
people would make fun of him calling him
a poo and he got a bunch of other Indian
actors and people in the industry to
talk about it and ever since there's
been a backlash about a poo a backlash
is it enough to see we're all afraid
everybody wants to avoid a controversy
and everybody doesn't want to say but
it's a great character and it's and by
the way it's based on a stereotype some
of its true because there are a lot of
Indian store owners there's no store
owner at 7-eleven which isn't an insult
our hard-working group of people
obviously they also make up a large part
of an important economy in tech and
everything else all over the place but
it's comedy it's a it's an interesting
character and I think just because
somebody had a negative experience
because you know I think it's a [ __ ]
cartoon and I think all these do
everybody's afraid everybody's [ __ ]
afraid the minute you call anything
right and and if you're sure they get
rid of mr. burns cuz he's an age are
they saying he's an ageist if you call
another new time you call enough for non
racist racist or if you keep calling us
calling and crying wolf when it's when
there ain't no wolf I don't think it
does anything to make the world better
well then the real wolves do come yeah
that's exactly right in the gym when the
real wolves come and they're out there
of course as we know as in evidence this
weekend at that synagogue etc that
that's that's the [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] and I think that this
just creates this weird false Marilyn we
buy it I don't buy they're going to drop
the boot character altogether they're
going
make a big deal out of it or anything
like that but they'll drop him
altogether just to avoid the controversy
why are they so scared of being on air
for 30 years
people are be shocked are told the well
is very pleased writing out a poo to
avoid controversy as a mistake if you
are a show about cultural commentary and
you are too afraid to comment on the
culture especially when it's a component
of the culture that you had a hand in
creating then you are then then you are
a show about cowardice I kind of agree
with I agree it's a real [ __ ] move it's
not a step forward or step backwards
just a massive step sideways after
having read all of these wonderful
scripts I feel like sidestepping this
issue doesn't solve it when the whole
purpose of art I would argue is to bring
us together and I agree with that too I
mean you know that abou there who this
is is that the voice though no the voice
that boos that that guy who's been on
everything is he is he who is a white
guy should be this guy white guy he does
voice for him mo yeah god forbid
he's on Howard Stern he's brilliant yeah
yeah it's a strange need to kind of did
you see that there's that there's a the
these three left-wing pretty left-wing
academics went out and started
publishing false sort of papers about
how like just about like dog humping and
how dog humping there there's like was
sort of essentially it was about gender
and race and all that seven they were
creating and these guys are on the left
but they were creating false narratives
and their papers were being accepted and
because and basically it was based on
not even real the scholarship but what's
going on in academia is a lot of like
these far left academics are there it's
a it's a political agenda it's not based
on science or anything else so they're
creating a narrative that people like
politicians everybody is picking up but
it's not necessarily true and so the
rest of us see this stuff and we're like
wow it's it's also just a great TV show
and funny what else are you making a big
deal out of it you know I'll be bummed
if we couldn't even make fun of like
like silly Asian things that happen in
the show yeah I would be bummed because
it's because comedy is not dangerous
it depends but you know we're not that
sensitive
we're not that weak and people can
weather it that's the people the ones
who are the louse are usually the ones
who are the biggest [ __ ] yes and I
think it's being I think the debate is
being controlled by the two percent on
either side oh yeah it's not the
majority no the rest of us are like what
just just like on the Instagram or u2 or
read any of the mean comments that's not
the majority that's well it's the
loudest you know people who are gonna
write this comes this professor I
biggest loser yeah this professor at
Columbia University was talking about
this so when you're a professor now and
you say something that might be
offensive or just might be just what
your point of view if one student
complains you get called in front of a
council and you don't know who that
student is you not even know what
allowed to know what the complaint is so
it's like a cruise missile so now you
have to be put on hold until the
grievance is settled and so he was like
and what's happening with the new
relation is this you get you get
prestige you get prestige from calling
racism anywhere you see it that so you
get status that way so there's an
incentive that way it's it's [ __ ]
it's all I what else we got all right
so after winning Game two a Red Sox
player Mookie Betts actually went out to
a public Chicago library late at night
and fed the homeless yep in Chicago yeah
in Chicago he went outside of a public
library [ __ ] is he in Chicago this is
after the game yeah I saw this he's a
good man he'll repeat the [ __ ] on some
public library oh no this isn't Boston
oh yeah cuz they played in Boston oh
they played in LA so they went back that
night can't believe they beat my
toddler's oh no this is Game three
that's cool man he says I've been
blessed with the thing I have I might as
well share it in to make sense he was in
Boston though huh
spotter providing hot meals to homeless
outside the Boston Public Library wonder
why he thought Chicago Kent maybe he was
Chicago pizza maybe 32 homers not 80
RBIs during the regular season
you're annoying with this game Brian I
was [ __ ] with him I haven't watched
one you were funny you would ask those
these poor guys run the Orpheum Theatre
dude can we get the game on I love I
love the world seriously I love it but I
was up but I don't give a [ __ ] about
hobbies but I kept calling damn time
Kevin come over on to Brenda and I was
like Dodgers are behind again now
nothing were severe weather fan and then
the LA Fairweather fans they jump on
these dodge I feel like a lot of LA fans
are that way right I'm right now
everyone's all into football now yeah
but when they're cheering at a bar like
in LA I feel like it's like it's like
listening to a bunch of dudes speaking
French who don't speak French like
they're they're saying the words but
they don't know what they're saying
[ __ ] Pittsburgh I'm doing stand-up at
The Improv during the playoffs and I'm
not exaggerating eighty percent of that
[ __ ] audience had Pittsburgh jerseys
on I'm not exaggerating they annoy me
know what else you got one of the
current events was that the longest
Series game 18 innings you know that one
the third game my favorite the next day
the this Brian saw me just dude how
about that game last night pretty crazy
crazy boring
I don't watch anything that I don't eat
anything disagree I don't want to watch
it that long no I disagree cuz I don't
know when it's gonna happen like you
never know what the first the next
baddest that's not crazy boring to me it
was a full other game longest game in
back-to-back how long 712 something a.m.
but then three and three something a.m.
and I'm still asleep in my phone on line
one oh and I woke up and it was when
Monty I thought it was my point
you fellas well no I was drinking wine
and I kind of fell asleep I'm a huge
Dodgers fan bro my Dodgers lost even if
the UFC the UFC's too long that's my
favorite sport to watch that three when
you watch the prelims on Fox the main
card my time you eat the main menu like
Jesus Christ let's just get through this
so I got way too long that would be like
just two people fighting each other for
that long not like a whole city
fight too much but no I was up at a
sleeping at 12 something where I live
and I'm like way up high and there's
bars and clubs below me so people stayed
up watching the game and then one
it's uh it woke me up so freaking fast
like with our streets honking yes all
sleeping Oh will you live by this but
I'm like all the way up
yeah but downtown by the state yeah it's
just bars first part big deal you know
don't pooh-pooh it story yeah man he
does that you know what you do that all
the time you stop everything you're like
whatever so anything well no actually
the bars went crazy the bars late well
he lives downtown yeah but it's why the
sting but they don't know that so I'm
like well no he knows 40 stories up I
know but he's 40 stories up he's in the
tallest building not all right this is a
funny story I don't know much about it
but uh there's a thief that looked just
like David Schwimmer have you seen the
real thief I suppose leave it looks
identical don't well this is David's
recreation of it as you can see here and
that's the real thief but get the little
crazy
no I'm stealing it looks like all right
mm-hmm
a bunch of beer and then David Schwimmer
did he just read it did they freeze it
like this though they do swimmers yes
I've seen the frozen one where it looks
just like him they just posit when he
does that it's so funny man yeah good
for him Blackpool police video what's
Blackpool I don't know sounds racist too
you want to see another all right these
are getting kind of crazy but this is
like crazy Hein too funny
okay so I don't want to get too into the
bombing but we found out that the pipe
bomber was a stripper back in the day
that was like yes this was him and he
used to get competitive with the other
dancers and he would threaten to infect
them with HIV so did he have HIV no he
said that he would get a syringe filled
with HIV filled blood yeah and stab him
with it huh so you're saying he was a
bad guy this is surprising he's [ __ ]
crazy it was Native American I guess huh
that's what I saw because the the choker
I believe he has he believed
as he's partially Native American I
don't know but he's crazy and has that
weird hair Wow he worked as an exile
let's do this year's mom did he really
yep oh yeah and then his mom kicked him
out he's letting his fans there man well
living out of his van
take it easy and lose there and oh and
by the way his facebook base was
basically like I'm gonna do this it's
like one threat after another
the bombs none of them went off or
anything like that right
they found one today in Atlanta another
one yes it was supposed to be for CNN
but after the initial scare CNN had all
of their mail shipped out to a facility
somewhere within the states that get
screened before the end to the actual
office they found one this morning
listen to this we're told says our once
got so jealous of a rival dancer he
taped tunic and lids to the bottom of
his boots and threatened to stomp the
dancers face and cut him up and when
people laughed at him he became enraged
and said just wait I'm gonna take this
guy out hmm all right I mean sounds like
a really stable guy I'm gonna tape tunic
and lids that's kind of like Jesus
Christ mean no one's gonna take it take
a while plus you're gonna tape and then
are you gonna walk over here you coming
a mile away you think this through are
you gonna tap-dance mile slippery it is
on this floor on the tunic I'll just run
away from you you're crazy I'll just
change direction a lot Wow look at him
what a mess doesn't know what happened
to his hair how about his mom was like
you gotta get out what happened is here
he's 57 so well what is it a pleasure
spray like LeBron used it for a while
Brian use it anyone look like spring
just came from the set schooled my scalp
they they they go they paint my scalp
yeah does my hair look thicker yes yeah
because they go they take off they take
do that they thicken it yeah yeah and
then they that's what they do and they
use mousse I have a little cowlick here
for my hair straight back and it when
I'm on set the always paint it black
yeah no I'm not going bald like yeah but
on camera
yep you can see your talaq yep so what
do they do with him does that what heat
that's what he did he must be a very
vain I just I said he was a male
stripper yeah
to give that's impressive it's got a
good body no he usually looks like Kaka
no well he is caucus oh yes piece of
[ __ ]
what else but but I believe the none of
the bombs worked and weren't even rigged
to work right I think some were rigged
no I don't think they were I think all
of them were just a PVC pipe some kind
of explosive aerial it looks weird it
doesn't look well that painted on it
looks like she painted not but but he
paints it he probably combs it back and
puts a net net on it mmm
or it's in a tight tight ponytail a
tight ponytail some would say the
tightest it's the Thai team it's him
that tightest ponytail of all time it's
pulling his eyes into you see how his
eyes are going in two different
directions that's how far I go man yeah
he looks like he looks like a very sad
man how about this one
so tickets for the last Cavs game
against the Nets were going for $2
Jesus why why is that
explain that LeBron is on the team
anymore bronze not there so they you
know they don't really have too many
guys yet Kevin Love he's injured now
then there were own six now and the knee
so they just got rid of head coach
there's rebuilding man yeah LeBron
leaves he's a guy I'm good you know gets
me when I went to Cleveland when I
played Cleveland this great club called
hilarities and I'm not joking I think
probably 50% of the people I spoke to
we're talking still talking about LeBron
leaving Cleveland and windows and what
it did to the city there's what he left
the first time I went to Miami they were
so upset because because just to just
ruin everything right support and raise
there that you leave you know zoom
worksites so I didn't even know the
Brahmas born and raised there I did not
know I don't know how okay but it was
really why because it was like such a
huge thing for all of them I was like
but economically I think it is a city
yeah one man they're doing better now
but yeah what else you got I saw this I
don't know how hilarious but this is
hilarious so 50 cent claims have bought
200 seats at a gyro concert just so that
there
empty there near the front too [ __ ]
hilarious that's a great way to get
packets hundred comic did this to
another one how funny with oh my god
that's a great at three thousand dollars
worth I was there only fifteen bucks
each so it's three thousand dollars
worth then put his show was only he's
only gonna sit two hundred people no no
it's just a chunk of it near on so when
people when you perform he the whole lot
and they probably roped it off and [ __ ]
oh my god that's so obnoxious I wonder
if that's actually true that's a step
posted LOF if teen dollars a pop you
can't lose I'll take two hundred it was
a Groupon discount to he made fun of me
for that for some reason and then this
is fifties post on it oh that's a joke
that's fabulous that's God that'd be
great he sat right in the middle there
I'd be funny as [ __ ] that's hilarious
usually fifty cents not great on
Instagram but this one was good any I
don't know how many times he's actually
telling the truth either right seems
like he's lied about a lot of a lot of
stuff he lied didn't he lie about making
five hundred million on vitamin water
and [ __ ] it came in mine we made a lot
for sure that came out but then fighting
rampage and all that crap too
yeah that's I mean I don't think you
bankrupt bankruptcy stuff kind of
screwed yeah some weird stuff but all
good what else best Donald Trump this is
from Mashable so they're just saying
that this is a this kind of describes
Trump's whole life story where he didn't
close he couldn't close an umbrella so
he just left it on the stairs look how
he does in a speech to the Future
Farmers of America and then a campaign
rallies digital at night address the
media here for the first time since the
shooting at this synagogue in Pittsburgh
called in terrible terrible thing
something has to be done about the hate
in America it's just like you front
[Laughter]
that is the food tug if I was president
I be so tempted to do that I would
describe the serial I would just drop it
where it was easy throw it in I would
just take them around like just be a
litter bug do everything you want just
[ __ ] I watch this [ __ ] woman in
these these these two these two elderly
black women in this really nice Mercedes
and she had a whole tray you know you
have a whole tray of like in and out
with the SONA dude she just I'm right
next to her she just rolled down a
window and just went she's wet and just
like let it slide off her hand with
total contempt like that I went I go I
go like this I go boom boom she and I go
all right and she didn't even look at me
she didn't give her a buzz went right
back to talking to her friend I was like
I mean that [ __ ] I saw some savage mood
to move in Whole Foods yesterday I saw
this lady go up that they just released
you could see they just put a hot tray
of doughnuts I saw sleek around she has
a shopping cart and I mean like a mom
yes reaching girls donors just rolling
on eating the phone I've seen I've seen
the other day and Whole Foods I saw a
woman look like a cross her in great
shape walk around and that she's walking
around everything and before I know it
she's digging in that salad bar and just
mm-hmm
she had an entire meal she was stealing
fun to say she was literally I want to
say she stole food like it lay with that
done I'm like those are good huh you're
gonna pay for that or it's kind of drive
me nuts oh you think you're gonna yeah
that down like be about this woman she
ate everything she had an entire meal
she had an Indian [ __ ] I was like you
have rice and chicken on a plate and
you're eating it out of the thing you're
eating all of it she was just completely
awful I would do that if I was the
president I just walk in any restaurant
and just walk in the back and make
myself a place I'd walk up to people's
plates and go hey man I'm doing that
yeah enjoying your freedom oh let me
taste some of that a little records give
me this
yeah what else you got do you the other
movie tropic thunders you guys watch it
[ __ ] alright sick
Shaun White dressed up as this character
will simple Jack do you know what
character [ __ ] yeah if you don't I will
love you I'll show you the rental
heiress are they mad now because yes
they're outraged by it no way the
essential Special Olympics yeah
tell especial em to go [ __ ] themselves
together let me in that race we beat the
[ __ ] of all this comedy drama there's a
fake trailer in the movie in the Ben
Stiller in the movie his character got
just a [ __ ] were abused for some people
made fun of them they always taken
hostage they made him play this movie
over and over in a real shitty way to
Sean Penn thing that's his real life by
the way
[Music]
I like we touch well I'm not a rabbit
like that
listen I think it's all hilarious and it
doesn't so Shaun White did that great
cousin people special olympics he paying
his face like he was the hostage in the
movie - that's what's funny about it
they made him pay his face like that
special needs parents get sensitive I
get it but it's like I get it yeah I get
it but it's also like again it relax
everybody
also it's he's playing off he's he's in
a costume of a fictional character in a
comedic movie yeah come on man there's
way more outrageous stuff I've seen that
make fun of people in Special Olympics
then yeah john waite dressing up as a
fictional but we also have to talk about
intent like he's not the intent behind
it agree and that seems to be a taken
out of the [ __ ] whole equation did
you intend to and you know when you
apologized like when you apologized like
megyn kelly apologized right I don't I
don't watch a show I don't know I don't
think the show was working anyway but it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter you
can't apologize it doesn't matter you're
just done I agree with intent they'll be
it's like he's at a Halloween party he's
playing simple Jack yeah and none of us
are really thinking about that it's just
a costume like oh that's the been silly
yeah I'm not thinking [ __ ] dude kids who
have special needs are gonna see that
via - no they're not no you are
don't the mom or the daddy yes what else
you got Jen that's ridiculous
oh do you want it so this is a pretty
bad one but this is in the news I want
to take this cat it's a luster Vic I
remember I got in trouble it because I
perform there least err is it it's least
er I don't think I don't know sure if
it's the same place alright keep going
yeah well the owner just died yesterday
he was confirmed dead after the
helicopter crashed is a billionaire Thai
billionaire dude loved [ __ ] man loved he
was beloved by fans he would give away a
lot of free stuff at the games free food
drinks merchandise he was a very
charitable
[ __ ] man and those those private
helicopters those private plane - yeah
there's another billionaire in England
who died
who's flying helicopters not recently
but [ __ ] yeah you can have all the money
in world cancer and helicopters yeah I
don't know goddang do they say white
crashed was he flying him so easy one of
those no no no he had somebody else
flying the plane they haven't confirmed
who else was in the plane with him right
now or I mean the helicopter there's
like five other people who's like five
or six other people they haven't
confirmed who they were but they crashed
on site at the stadium I guess that's
his thing he does that he flies into the
games and lands in the middle and then
takes off so he just took off and then
something happened something not
functioned that's such a bummer man and
did he die in the in the plane or this
was in Thailand no those was in the UK
oh here's one for you it's from last
week I think so it says off-white the
veranda you like to wear a lot cursor
past Gucci and Balenciaga is the most
popular brand in the world yes surely
off-white what is explain to me get me
up to date on halfway uh it's from a guy
who was part of Kanye's kind of group
Virgil Abel who went on to now he's the
head of Louis Vuitton he's that head up
create a Louis Vuitton and his line is
off-white so there's like off white
Nikes that you probably know some the
shoes I was wearing there he just does
like a his spin on it it looks like kind
of the off-white how would you it's kind
of like more of a roll like InDesign
type of vibe that he goes mm-hmm like in
the process it's cool stuff I didn't
know it's the most popular brand I was
insane that kind of stuff they're not
giving it away either
well that's why the worst example you
but I mean this kind of thing this label
yeah but not really those are terrible
though here's where would I get would I
not get those shoes okay you know me I
wear some [ __ ] I would not wear
if I click like those Nikes like they
just do subtle little things to them now
what am I gonna pick that up now now am
I get of now am I gonna mano am I gonna
buy the Jordan one off whites for my
comedy special in January yes Brian are
they under a thousand probably not Wow a
special night Oh for a special shoe
I now respect yeah I know those are it
there those are understand top left chin
that's those huh cool you don't know
we're just the regular ones you need the
ones that have you just need the ones
that are made by those special shoe furs
that stuff but I mean I'm just saying it
don't make them anymore bro you could
get those somewhere though the regular
ones couldn't you you could you know you
could some special shoes but you just
want to buy the off ways to wear them
once
well I'd wear those more than once but
or always all right frame now do you do
you need to keep the [ __ ] plastic
thing on the tag Allen keep on a few of
them usually I don't Virgil says you
shouldn't do it he doesn't he's like
don't leave okay but some shoes on Mike
shut up okay right like my cons I'm like
I want people to know you want people to
know they're all white like my Blazers I
don't yeah
do you think you're shallow those are my
favorite shoes yeah those are
comfortable shoes I own yeah they
support your arches click on the grid
the green laces ones you see those yeah
that's and he put in the green laces now
they just drop the Serena Williams off
lights that Blazers that are dope as
[ __ ] and I'm you know I can't decide no
in the Jordans for the no I can't do it
I get no and I understand maybe by both
pregnant a woman Carlos up nope nope
nope talk about that actually
I knew you'd like those are it come to
Daddy come to Daddy
I'm not mad at those actually you
shouldn't be yeah I like a cool snake
like that I'm all too aware it's not for
you dude I like an oh I like a cool
trainer a wolf gray excuse me
wolf gray is not for me excuse me I'm an
old gray wolf dude
not a I'm not an owl I've been meaning
to talk to you about that wolf and
squared away what are you looking at the
shoes are so busted
they're a little busted yeah where'd you
get those they're made by a Japanese
designer don't care what the in Japan
you get on my 97 I got them in Japan
from a boutique Buchi boutique store
that cat works at exactly exactly what
else you got Jen that's pretty much it
now who's hurt my feet so hurt my toes
yeah too skinny in the front maybe
something about him weird scrunch me out
a little bit some weird that's fine you
know that you dude those uh Pumas that
they gave you the comfiest [ __ ] only
ever one size too small
ah killed me because I like let's go
shoe shopping San Fran find something
different okay
then those cuz I bought some too boots
and they hurt my feet too Oh your
footprints not no problem it's just a
little tag in there sometimes you learn
about it I feel that's some shoes
they're they're great shoes and they're
comfortable for a while booth and then
they break me down see my two boots are
comfy is what you know where that
happens though is in my workout shoes I
got the Kyrie Irving's the Lucky Charms
Nikes sure and they're bright pink shoes
Lucky Charms all over but the thing is
is those I workout him so much when I do
my classes the soccer mom classes they
they get too loose yeah any shoe that
stays tie up I think adidas has a new
basketball shoe that's gonna stay tight
for me I've been looking at them we'll
see
well well there you go you need to add
to your collection collection oh yeah
maybe dude Sam Cisco will go shoe shop
and keep everyone posted okay you just
shut your mouth you know you know
dropping some hot shoes lately John
Varvatos always has strong shoe should
go there in San Fran maybe I don't mind
that yeah they're gonna spend a little
bread and you got it I spent some money
flex on it what do you do yeah don't you
do it
I get nervous with this stuff let's look
through them let's look through the
collection that's all I would wear for
Brian nah Poppleton why they say in
France we're getting closer
no anybody knows nope nope nope those
are no you can't wear regular chucks
no it's rodents thing those are bad
don't like how it will find subgrade
we're not gonna go through all of them
right now like it does unless you want
to buy me some patent leather pants
unless you have some assless chaps and
start sucking dick those aren't for you
okay good neither of those yeah but you
know what I'm looking I like it so I
might pick myself up a bit anyways you
like to decorate your feet Brennan I do
eyeballs to your feet but speaking of
San Francisco the only thing we won't be
doing is uh shoe shopping will be a
table comedy club that's Friday Saturday
early shows both almost sold out less
than ten tickets left the only should
take it's available in bunches with your
friends or the late shows Cobb's comedy
club San Francisco San Francisco this
Friday and Saturday then after that the
following weekend I'm in Sacramento that
is November 16th and 17th punchline
Friday and Saturday only after that I'm
in New York City Gotham comedy club New
York City November 30th through December
first then New Mexico and then the big
one January 19th I'm shooting my
one-hour comedy special for show time at
Spreckels Theatre in San Diego get your
tickets now one night only two shows
January 19th t fat Kate calm for tickets
but San Francisco I'm coming with Bryan
Callen this Friday coming out of day
tickets at T fat K calm see you Friday
and Saturday Sam Fran this the final kid
we're out yeah